Let's think first how to get e to the x by itself. Before we do anything else,
we need to subtract 23 from both sides. That leaves us with 3e to the x equals
323. To get e to the x alone, all we need to do now is to divide both sides by
3. Now, I could come up with a decimal for the right-hand side here, but I
don't think it's going to be very pretty. So, I'm just going to leave this as
an improper fraction for now. So we have e to the x equals 323 over 3. Now, I
want to get x by itself, and what do I need to do? Well, I need to take the log
of both sides and the base of that log needs to be the same as the base we have
here, which is e. So I have ln of e to the x equals ln of 323 over 3. We know
that the left-hand side will reduce just to x. That's why we picked a log of
this base after all. To figure out what the right-hand side evaluates to, we
have to use our calculator. Okay, so natural log of 323 divided by 3. Double
check that we've add the correct thing here and that looks right to me. That
equals 4.679 and so on. We said we wanted our answer to just two decimal
places, so that should be 4.68.